do you know what sugar babies have to do
to make
money there are these are sugar baby
confessions a brutally honest peek
behind the curtain into the world of
transactional
dating now according to urban dictionary
a very
um
reputable source they say a sugar baby
is a young lady who is financially
pampered and cared for by her sugar
daddy in exchange for companionship one
sugar baby said transactional
arrangements are very straightforward
and all the cards are on the table well
technically the man's credit card is on
the table but i'm pumped
hey yo so this is what sugar babies do
they um
are financially pampered and cared for
by these uh
richer
daddies yeah as they are mommies or
mommies yeah
i'm a sugar baby yeah i'll go out and
sit
you you're getting taken care of by
someone kim k yeah kim k there it is
thanks kim thanks uh pete so here are a
couple stories uh from sugar baby
confessions that we're talking about
right now like the one lady who said
technically the man's card is on the
table but she does like it because it's
straightforward and transactional it's a
business relationship
next girl says i'm a professional sugar
baby
and i have several
seven
different simultaneous
sugar daddies right now
i love learning about all the different
professions i.e doctor lawyer hollywood
director and investment banker so she's
shooting for the stars just google that
you have to and she's trying out new
hobbies i.e golf sailing fly fishing etc
all from like of a diverse collection of
daddies all right all right all right
all right so she says it opened up my
world to many new experiences cultures
and ways of life good for you sugar baby
number two
of the year
she says when i was 19
i had a sugar daddy okay okay i was in
college and needed to pay loans i hear
you girl this man who was like 68 or
something she says had reached out to me
and i jokingly replied
i am now 32 and we are married oh
boom this is like a complete anna nicole
smith situation gotten that written all
over talk about transactional so when
she was 19 he was 68.
okay girl so now
that guy's like
okay exactly so now
she's 32 so that's what 13 years that's
19 that's one that's that's 13 years
difference he was 68 so he's
am i doing this right no no no no no no
no yes he's 68. she's okay so she's 31
now how old is she 32. he's 81 now
she's 32 and he's 81.
19 plus 13. that's 32. boom 68 plus 13.
okay that's yeah that's 81. exactly
so she's 32 81 she's dating anthony
fauci
pretty much remember anna nicole smith
yeah yeah that's pretty much that
exactly let's go wait for him to die
um
anyway that's sugar baby talking about
playing the long at the end of this you
tell me what sugar baby you would prefer
the new cosmo article number four says
i'm currently working as a sugar baby
hell yeah to help with college much like
sugar baby number three that money some
experiences haven't been so good with
the men i was just
uh the men i work with i was were
pushing boundaries and doing things that
they didn't have permission to do
girls and so on and some of it also
isn't so bad uh sugar baby number four
you be careful out there you be careful
out there uh don't do anything that you
don't want to do yeah uh you are well
within your sugar baby rights to leave
that sugar daddy and find a better sugar
daddy for your own
yeah don't do anything weird get out of
that
anyway this is this this is all started
with this hypergamy uh story the act of
dating up yeah uh now we're talking
about
sugar babies dating wealthy sugar
daddies
sugar baby number five this is the last
one she says i had a thing with a guy in
his late 50s when i was in my early 30s
it lasted a few years he paid for
everything fancy dinners luxury hotels
designer clothes the whole thing i
honestly had a blast and the kicker was
it was the absolute best sex of my life
good for you sugar baby number five talk
about that sugar talk about that sugar
you know what lady uh uh he did pay for
everything because that's kind of the
whole point that's what i was gonna say
i would hope so shockingly he paid for
everything no [ __ ]
i didn't know the whole point of the
sugar daddy thing i thought was just bad
look there's a moral of the story and i
doubt we have too many sugar babies or
sugar daddy's even listening right here
well let's see what if i
should give a sugar
baby
any advice we talked about this we
talked about you know
some different stories right there i
would be
uh i would get something that was
long-lasting so we talked about the girl
who got her college paid for maybe you
get a guy to help start up a business
maybe a life-changing trip or an
upgraded mindset maybe you'll remember
the girl we talked about i'm learning
new things new hobbies okay great
but if you do the typical cars clothes
jewelry fancy dinner things
next thing you know you're gonna be an
old broke sugar baby and nobody wants an
old broke sugar baby that's embarrassing
so
be very careful with what you spend your
sugar baby money on yeah um also you're
right like make that dude if you got a
sugar daddy get your bills paid for get
your bills paid get your college degree
um grade upgrade
and then you can go and get your little
uh fancy little things but most people
don't have you know elevated mindset
like that most people who are being
sugar babies aren't like yes i'm using
him to pay for my college and then
medical school and everything is uh
progressing nicely and next thing you
know i'll have a sugar baby degree and i
will not no longer need a sugar daddy
these are the times most sugar babies
like i want a new purse i want some new
heels yeah i want some sugar i want some
sweet and low i want it out why are you
saying it like that i don't know i just
feel like that's how it sugar baby yeah
that's exactly these are the times i
wish i was a woman
i'm not kidding yeah yeah i get it but i
would dude even if you are and i'm not
even disparaging sugar babies or sex
workers or any like do what you got to
do
but you can be
like
you could be a porn star and also have
an elevated mindset you could be a sugar
baby and understand budgeting and saving
investing and paying off college debt
like you can be that or you could be a
sugar baby or porns or whatever it is
and just be an idiot and spend all your
money on crap cars clothes jewelry meals
whatever and still end up broke
so your profession i could care less
it's about the mindset what would you
say to the sugar daddy uh
as far as the aspect of like
wealth and like building wealth and save
that money like it is that in your like
business plan to have a sugar baby is it
you write that off as a dude i've never
been a sugar daddy i don't understand do
you know anyone that is i live in miami
buddy you best believe there's some okay
there's some there's some sugar being
sprinkled yeah there are some daddies
with some sugar there's some daddies
with them sugar but a lot of these guys
look they're probably well off they're
making money i mean we talked about the
girl she said she's dated a doctor a
lawyer a hollywood director and
investment banker these guys are making
money do you ever have any conversation
with these guys and be like so what's
that like bro no does she because i
doubt that have a boyfriend
you know really
i mean i think so i think i think sugar
daddy's more will be like yeah that's
that's the girl i take care of and she
takes care of me
all right i've got a goal i gotta hunt
down some sugar daddies yeah find out
what they're doing and maybe we can get
some sugar babies on the size cats do
some interviews do both i think we
should do both we don't have to say
goals 2022 goals business plan um and
then uh yeah see what that's like
anyway uh whether you're a sugar baby
sugar daddy sugar mama whatever it is
mindset is the most important thing if
you're going to get someone just to pay
your bills
get something long lasting out of it
yeah rather than a handbag make sure he
or she is at least 50 years of age that
we got some time
right right as opposed to but not too
much he started when he was 68 now well
no i think yeah i think that's good you
know it's quicker get it over with
cooper
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken